ho passato gli ultimi dieci anni in
spiaggia e prima che cominciate a
invidiarmi un po troppo in realtà li ho
passati più a raccogliere spazzatura ea
cercare di capire che cosa era tutta
questa plastica che trovavo in spiaggia
da dove veniva è come cercare di
fermarla c'erano molte cose che non mi
quadra vano e non mi quadrano ancora
adesso come come sia arrivato un
frigorifero in spiaggia un telefono o un
asciugacapelli e quello che veramente
non riuscivo a capire è come mai
come mai come mai così tante persone
andassero in spiaggia a pulirsi le
orecchie questo veramente non riuscivo a
spiegarmi quello che ho capito invece è
che gran parte della plastica che
troviamo in spiaggia sono poca parte di
questa spiaggia di meno di questa
plastica arriva dal mare
la gran parte invece viene dalle coste e
viene dall entroterra è una parte
importante la metà degli oggetti che
troviamo in spiaggia sono in realtà
oggetti usa e getta di uso quotidiano e
sono un po la somma di tanti piccoli
comportamenti quotidiani che abbiamo
ciascuno di noi moltiplicati per milioni
di volte
e allora ora finalmente il mare di
plastica diventato un argomento di
grande attualità per fortuna anche se
sembra più che il problema che l'allarme
che suscita sia più rivolto alle isole
di plastica del pacifico piuttosto che
al mare di casa nostra
e allora come diceva luca giustamente
una cosa abbiamo capito anche o
perlomeno l'ho capita io che la plastica
un materiale è meraviglioso non dobbiamo
demonizzarlo le nostre automobili i
nostri aerei adesso sono leggerissimi
consumano pochissima poca
carburante ha salvato la plastica
salvato tanti animali pensate le
tartarughe a agli elefanti salva anche
le nostre vite
il problema non è la plastica il
problema è come noi stiamo usando la
plastica che è un materiale fantastico
utilissimo leggero resistente e lo
usiamo per degli usi appunto che si
esauriscono in pochissimi minuti e poi è
talmente poco costosa che ci
dimentichiamo e non facciamo caso o
attenzione a come la smaltiamo e allora
da da questa idea ea cercare di capire
come uscire da questo problema abbiamo
creato un progetto europeo in cui è una
grande alleanza fra tutti gli amanti del
mare fra tutti i velisti subacquee
diportisti pescatori sportivi i ragazzi
delle scuole gli insegnanti tutti i
cittadini ea tutti stiamo chiedendo di
fare tre cose molto semplici non buttare
raccogliere e cercare di usare meno
plastica usa e getta sono somma delle
cose di estrema semplicità e forse
addirittura banali però andiamo a vedere
un attimo che cosa vuol dire non buttare
per esempio non buttare vuol dire fare
più attenzione
io sono certa che nessuno qua di voi
tutti i sacchetti della spazzatura per
le strade
però quando andiamo in spiaggia e
lasciamo un sacchetto in un contenitore
è strapieno guardate che esattamente la
stessa cosa perché basta che passi un
cane un gatto un uccello
apro al sacchetto io a quel punto tutta
la spazzatura che è contenuta si
spargerà e andrà a finire in mare
in questi diciotto minuti di
chiacchierata in italia si fumeranno due
milioni e mezzo di sigarette e a
giudicare dai marciapiedi come li
vediamo in tutte le città o nelle
spiagge molte di queste sigarette vanno
a finire per terra
allora fumatori per poi per piacere fate
attenzione perché i mozziconi di
sigarette sono di plastica intrisi di
sostanze tossiche e quindi ci vuole
veramente molto poco per eliminare uno
dei rifiuti più frequenti sulle spiagge
mozziconi e accendini questi sembrano
oggetti assolutamente così innocui
allegri colorati e divertenti sempre
plastica sono è una parte importante
addirittura un terzo dei rifiuti che
troviamo in spiaggia derivano da persone
che sono andati in spiaggia a divertirsi
quindi sono giocattoli penne occhiali
creme solari e cose del genere o
merendine devo puntare di qua
quindi attenzione di nuovo con un po più
di attenzione possiamo eliminare una
parte importante di rifiuti
ma l'attenzione verso la pulizia del
mare deve partire anche dall entroterra
e palloncini ce lo dimostrano
tutto quello che va su naturalmente poi
scoppia e ricade giu e quando sono in
mare ai palloncini assumono un po la
stessa forma e le stesse movenze di
meduse o calamari che sono il cibo
preferito di pesci tartarughe e uccelli
quindi palloncini sì ma non facciamoli
volare per favore ma l'attenzione del
mare parte dalle nostre case nei nostri
gabinetti per piacere non dobbiamo
buttare nulla perché questi sono alcuni
dei rifiuti che troviamo più spesso
sulle spiagge e anche questi quindi
abbiamo risolto il problema non saranno
tutte le persone che andavano in
spiaggia pulirsi le orecchie a merano
tutte persone che si pulivano le
orecchie e poi gettavano i bastoncini
non nel cestino ma nel gabinetto quindi
un poco di attenzione in più riusciamo a
eliminare una parte importante di
rifiuti dalle nostre docce parte
quotidianamente una nuvola di frammenti
di plastica verso il mare sono gli
sfoghi anti guardate da queste
fotografie quanta plastica è contenuta
in un singolo flacone anche qua per
fortuna dall'anno prossimo saranno
proibiti ma già da subito possiamo
evitare di comprarli semplicemente
guardando nel i ticket e se c'è scritto
polietilene evitiamo questa è la strada
preferita per i rifiuti per finire in
mare i nostri fiumi
quindi particolare attenzione dobbiamo
prestare quando siamo vicino ai fiumi
per l'appunto giusto per farvi vedere lo
stillicidio continuo di spazzatura che
c'è che arriva in mare attraverso i
fiumi
questo basta un tappo che si formi un
tappo sotto le arcate di un ponte e
vediamo effettivamente quanta plastica
dall'entroterra arriva al mare e infine
l'attenzione
dobbiamo por che dobbiamo porre anche
quando vogliamo svuotare le nostre
cantine siamo sicuri che il dondolo
della nonna oltre i ciclo di nostro
nipote vada a finire veramente l'isola
ecologica o non venga abbandonato sotto
il primo ponte attenzione a chi
affidiamo i nostri oggetti raccogliere
raccogliere è importante perché nessun
paese al mondo alle capacità economiche
di andare a pulire il mare il momento
migliore per pulire una spiaggia e
d'inverno quando ci sono le burrasche e
perché dobbiamo raccogliere perché
abbiamo ormai veramente testimonianze
infinite dei danni che la plastica possa
fare agli animali che ci si infilano
dentro si intrappolano mangiano
soffocano
per non parlare poi di altri impatti
quanto costa quanto cosa a ripulire le
nostre spiagge sono un danno per la
navigazione i rifiuti sono veramente noi
ci stiamo focalizzando tanto sulle
famigerate isole di plastica del
pacifico senza renderci conto che nel
nostro mediterraneo c'è la stessa
concentrazione di microplastiche che c'è
in queste famigerate isole e perché è
presto detto il nostro mare un lago
tutto quello che ci è finito dentro è
ancora lì e se non lo vediamo è
semplicemente perché si è frantumato e
quindi raccogliamo raccogliamo degli
oggetti finché sono ancora interi perché
se no se rilasciamo in spiaggia si
frantumeranno sotto l'azione del sole
del sale delle onde fino a frammenti
così piccoli che poi a quel punto è
veramente impossibile recuperarli e non
pensiate che questi siano più innocue
anzi forse sono ancora più subdoli e più
pericolosi perché poi alla fine
diventano a portata di bocca del
plancton che il primo anello della
catena alimentare e quindi raccogliamo
raccogliamo da soli sergio ci ha appena
detto portiamoci due sacchetti quando
andiamo a fare il bagno
coinvolgiamo i nostri amici e per
fortuna nel nostro grande progetto
abbiamo coinvolto tanti subacquee perché
se ci sembra orrendo quello che abbiamo
trovato in spiaggia e quello che avete
visto in spiaggia in realtà la gran
parte dei rifiuti si trova sul fondo del
mare quindi sommozzatori sono i più
unici che riescono andare a pulire sul
fondo del mare ma se fare attenzione e
raccogliere sono due cose fondamentali
la cosa più importante è in assoluto è
ripensare il nostro rapporto con con la
plastica senza essere portale bani in
realtà io sono probabilmente vestita di
plastica però la metà dei rifiuti che
troviamo in spiaggia e usa e getta e di
nuovo stiamo utilizzando un materiale
che virtualmente eterno per degli
utilizzi che si esauriscono in
pochissimo tempo ci siamo un po
ubriacati di questo materiale che
allegro comodissimo nella vita di tutti
i giorni
dobbiamo però imparare a utilizzarlo per
quegli impieghi per i quali un materiale
così eterno da una vita così lunga sia
effettivamente giustificato quindi
ciascuno deve cercare nella vita di
tutti i giorni di trovare il modo per
diminuire l'uso di plastica usa e getta
sostituendolo con i materiali tipo il
vetro ad esempio ma attenzione che
l'abbia la bioplastica è una soluzione
ma non è la soluzione perché un
sacchetto di questi che vada a finire in
mare loro si decompongono in condizioni
di compostaggio industriale
se invece questo finisce in mezzo al
mare ci metterà mesi se non anni
se non anni a distruggersi e questo nel
frattempo se incontrano nel male se lo
mangia è spacciato lo stesso sulle
spiagge troviamo tantissime bottiglie
tappi di bottiglie e questo è uno dei
rifiuti che possiamo più facilmente
eliminare ogni italiano ha ciascuno di
noi di ciascuno di voi seduta in questa
sala consuma in media 200 litri di acqua
al giorno al mese all'anno 200 litri di
acqua all'anno in bottiglia e questo in
un paese dove
come l'italia dove l'acqua mediamente
buonissima quindi è un modo molto
semplice usiamo una borraccia evitiamo
di usare e di comprare tutta questa
acqua in bottiglia ed è un modo molto
rapido per abbattere il nostro uso di
plastica usa e getta
cioè che mi dice ma perché se io la
riciclo la mia bottiglietta allora la
bottiglietta di acqua la plastica della
bottiglietta di acqua non tornerà mai
essere una volta riciclata di nuovo una
bottiglietta diventerà qualcos'altro
tanto più se la bottiglietta d'acqua era
colorata quella plastica diventerà un
sacchetto della spesa un file o una
panchina ma di quante panchine abbiamo
bisogno noi e poi alla fine comunque
andrà smaltita e quindi non facciamo
altro che portare più in là al momento
in cui dovremmo smaltire questa plastica
la realtà è che noi non siamo in grado
di smaltire tutta questa spazzatura
tutto questi rifiuti che che stiamo
generando e quindi la soluzione
fondamentale è quella di diminuire
diminuire gli imballaggi soprattutto
cerchiamo di di comprare sfuso il più
possibile ricordiamoci ricordo usavamo e
sapone anziché il il sapone liquido la
cerchiamo di evitare situazioni tipo
queste che sono francamente assurde
allora basta basta veramente poco basta
un po di consapevolezza perciò per
diminuire il nostro uso e abuso di
plastica queste sono soltanto alcune
delle mille idee che che si possono
avere per per andare in questa direzione
basta basta soltanto questo per salvare
il mare ovviamente no perché un problema
così complesso non ha una singola
soluzione il problema della plastica
mare deriva dal fatto che abbiamo una
gestione dei rifiuti sbagliata a volte
illegale certamente non sufficiente però
abbiamo visto che una parte importante
dei rifiuti la generiamo noi nel nostro
comportamento quotidiano e quindi senza
di noi senza un impegno nostro
quotidiano
per esempio in come questo
la situazione di certo non si risolve la
buona notizia come vedete che veramente
basta poco basta un po di consapevolezza
e allora negli ultimi due anni da quando
è partito questo progetto abbiamo
coinvolto più di 10.000 persone che
hanno raccolto più di dieci tonnellate
di cose immaginate se fossimo
arrivassimo a 100.000 persone quanto
riusciremo a fare stiamo aiutando il
governo italiano e l'unione europea a
semplificare la questione dei rifiuti e
stiamo aiutando i pescatori a riportare
i rifiuti che raccolgono le loro reti a
mare
abbiamo incontrato migliaia di bambini
che hanno fatto la loro promessa al mare
danno lanciare i palloncini a non usare
mai più i bicchieri di plastica usa e
getta
abbiamo convinto tre sindaci a bandire
il lancio dei palloncini e anche grazie
al nostro lavoro lo stato italiano ha
proibito l'uso dei bastoncini per
orecchie di plastica all'inizio di
quest'anno e l'anno prossimo bandirà le
microplastiche nei cosmetici e allora
basta questo non basta dobbiamo
continuare certo se avessimo iniziato
vent'anni fa a quest'ora sarebbe stato
tutto molto più facile però c'è un
proverbio cinese meraviglioso che dice
il momento migliore per piantare un
albero e avere l'ombra era 20 anni fa e
secondo e prossimo momento è questo
grazie
[Applauso]